i couldn't begin this journey without
two women who have been
a part of my heart for over 20 years
we are friends we are fellow angels
please welcome my partners in crime and
life lucy liu
and cameron diaz
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh my god you guys it's hard to keep it
together man i just felt like bursting
into tears i'm just so happy we're all
together the three of us
i haven't seen you guys all well all
three of us together in
a very long time we all made charlie's
angels
we made it and we're making this show
and so when we sat around and thought
about
who is this you know first guest
nothing felt right nothing was there and
all of a sudden in like a divine
intervention i was like
cameron and lucy and everything fell
into place
massive congratulations this is really
major for you
i um listen you know everybody
says who's gonna be your first guest
it's like i mean we've been through
everything together you know well
everything
everything literally everything
i haven't been i haven't got
i haven't had a wedding that you guys
haven't been out i've been to all your
weddings i've been bleeding
to all of them like when our babies are
born
we hang out and we do the birthday party
thing
i can't believe we're all moms now
that's when i
got really emotional first i sent
cameron a video
and i'm saying hey listen i got at like
i want to ask you something
will you come on the show um which
i mean i've never done this in my life
because
i'm so comfortable i mean we have lived
together all over the world
so of course to save time i sent her a
video while i'm getting dressed
and you don't see anything i'm not that
dumb but i'm getting out of the shower
and i'm like ringing out of my towel
and i don't hear back from her for like
two days and i'm like this is weird
did i what is going on so i text her and
i'm like i don't care
about the question are you okay i don't
hear again for two days
i'm freaking out so i call her and i'm
like
what is going on i'm worried is
everything okay she's like i don't know
what you're talking about i'm like the
video
you didn't get my video turns out
a young boy watched the video
lucky him oh no
oh no by the way it's like seven minutes
long
oh my god there's
like epic i mean this is some material
secrets
material for like honestly he can use
this is going to last him three or four
years
i mean i you know i'm really like
hamming it up because it's
you know because it's you yeah that was
good i was like send me that video
immediately i need to know what is in
that video and
the whole while i'm just like cracking
up
because you need to send me this video
as well or do it through someone else
because i didn't get your other video
either
so then someone's like did you get her
videos like no
no i'm something's wrong with my phone
so i sent lucy this video
crying inviting her on the show saying
in her bathroom crying
i am in my bag she was dressed
i was fully clothed this time i didn't
take the risk
and she didn't get the video either come
on
i know i know you uh the thing that i
love
about our friendship is that we have
been there in all the big
and important moments we've also been
there
in the small moments and the casual
moments
and the reason we are such good friends
is because it's real
and we go through real stuff with each
other it's not a hollywood fairy tale
it's life is not there's no
aspect of life that's an actual
hollywood fairy tale
that's why it's a hollywood fairy tale
because it doesn't exist you want it's
aspirational it's hopeful
but life is constantly full of twists
and turns and
all of those things that happen over a
lifetime because truly it is now
a lifetime i mean 20 years is
a long time y'all like i'm i'm two years
away from 50.
you know that's nearly half my life we
have
charlie's angels as our sort of backdrop
that brought us together but then we get
to fill in
all of life together in real moments
which i just so appreciate so true it's
so well said honey i know
because it's like it's our touch point
you know yeah but then we have that
foundation and then we've obviously
grown and
learned and changed and i mean i know
that 20 years has gone by but i feel
like it was yesterday
i feel just as fresh and as young and as
you know
creatively uh i don't know excited as i
was when i started here's the thing
about charlie's angels is that it's
about
girls who can do all of these things
and love each other and don't have
competition
and support each other and laugh and
want to talk about
love and life so much that they actually
start to talk about love and life while
they're fighting because
women are so like that it all intersects
and that
is why i asked you guys here today is
because if you're gonna do something big
you wanna do it with your girlfriends
that's right
and
and i and i love being together
although are we really together
are we all together in this room are we
i feel
like we're connected in some way but
maybe for anyone watching
can you guess which one of us isn't
really here
welcome i'm the one in los
angeles
[Laughter]
[Music]
you gotta try this it's so incredible
the ether
little particles going out into space
and coming back or remastering into
this beautiful space you guys it's crazy
you should try it tingles
and if you guys want to know how that
awesome groundbreaking technology works
just go to our website at
[Music]
thedrewberrymoreshow.com